now there are lots of sub disciplines
within bioinformatics because
bioinformatics is an interdisciplinary
field
because we need computer scientists we
need biologists
we need even economic economists right
now right
so we need it's an interdisciplinary
feed so there is a development of new
algorithms and
you have statistics because the minute
you talk about big data
you need statistics because you want to
see if this one
single mutation is actually
statistically significant for us to say
yes this particular mutation causes that
particular disease
right and then we have an analysis and
interpretation of various types of data
including nucleotides amino acid
sequences protein domains and protein
structures
and how do we get structures to function
and all of those things and then the
development and implementation of tools
because we can have we can generate data
we can have computer scientists to
develop tools
to look at the data and we also need
without tools we cannot even mine and
look at this that that's what this
course you're going to be learning about
a lot of resources where there is data
but also you're going to be using tools
to be able to
use how do you use the data without
tools right but
we are going to be focusing just on this
aspect of nucleotides and
acid structures and all of that for the
first one right
now is informatics a new field what do
you think i really love to ask this
question to all my students and i get
different kinds of answers
so i would like to know of course i wish
i had some polling
uh set up so that we could have just
pulled now
what do you all think is bioinformatics
a new field
or not you can just type s or no answer
into the chat and we'll see
we'll just wait for a second and see
okay no bioinformatics is not a
is not a new field okay i'm seeing a
lot of near no no no no no that is
actually
no okay so bioinformatics is
actually you're right it's not a new
field right
so um where do you think it was born so
bioinformatics is not a new field
but where was bioinformatics actually
born who gave
to this whole field of bioinformatics
any guesses of which continent
when i went to school it was seven
continents i don't know how many
continents we have today
uh but howdy rosalind uh so you mean
wrestling franklin
okay who who where was it born which
continent was it born you think
any guesses of where bioinformatics was
actually born
asia okay that would be my guess as well
um x-ray crystallography chromatography
of dna
usa okay probably in europe okay so
we're covering a lot of different
continents here we covered asia you
covered europe
uh asia is coming up a lot europe is
coming up a lot
um uk yeah
sure okay so cuba okay good guess
actually i'm going to take someone who
just actually
may be one who made the protein atlas
okay we are actually coming really
really close
that is very true so bioinformatics says
actually i spent a lot of time on the
slide just because it's really fun to
see
how people think right where it was born
um
and um yes it was actually i'm going to
get closer to
uh i think it was parimalla um or
someone else said who uh usa
right so i think whoever said usa it is
actually correct so it was actually born
in the u.s
and uh it was actually i'm very proud to
say that it it was actually born in the
universities i work in
georgetown university and i think
pariamala you are actually right
it was actually the person who actually
made the protein atlas
and who is that person who made the
protein atlas
any guesses so
uh before i introduce um i have to give
tribute to this person robert ledley
he was a faculty at georgetown he
actually died from alzheimer's disease
and he was the person who actually
discovered the whole body ct scanner as
well
and he actually published a paper in
1959
where he said he predicted
that 50 years or 30 40 years from when
he wrote that paper
that we are going to be drowned in data
and we are going to be dealing with
biological data
he is the person who actually hired the
person to georgetown
who actually gave birth to the entire
field of bioinformatics
and she is actually officially now
called
the father and the mother of
bioinformatics she was declared the
father and mother mother of
bioinformatics by
david lipman who actually was the
director of
ncbi which we will talk about so yes
those of you who said it's a lady yes it
is a lady and she was the one and she
actually came up with
this atlas of protein sequence and
structures it was actually before my
time as well
in 1965 right so this is so in 1965 i
don't even know how many years
ago that was um where people used to
actually get sequences published in a
book
people used to sequence and send the
sequence to margaret de hoff
and she used to just publish this in a
book
and this book was the one that was
actually posted to all the scientists
around the world
and that is how they used to get the
protein sequences right
so now what were her other seminal
contributions yes someone said
i think it was uh who said in atlas
and what and she gave birth at that
point
she was a visionary she's considered a
missionary because people who are
visionaries
they already think what's coming 50
years down the road she was the one who
said well we are going to have a data
explosion
so let's create what is called a
database so she was the person who first
created the prudent database
and if any of you are visiting
washington dc sometime and you
visit georgetown i can take you to
actually the servers and
all the books that she published we
still have it because
you know i used to hate history uh in
school but now i love history and so i
have actually kept
all her papers and everything else as
everything was coming along
and she also came up with the single
letter code for amino acids
i'm sure you all know what single
electron amino acid letter code is right
i'm sure
i don't want to busy on that but is
there any reason
do you think that she came up with the
single letter amino acid code for
example glycine
gly is gene right alanine
ala is a right so do you know why
yeah efficiency but other than the
efficiency of course it's very efficient
right today we look at it and it's
extremely efficient
but think in 1960s why would she come up
with a single letter amino acid little
code
what do you all think easier
representation yes that is definitely
true
but other than that you know you all are
in a generation where we have gigabytes
of data in your phone
you're carrying gigabytes of data in
your cell phone so you can do this whole
thing in a cell phone right
back then yeah it was lack of
computation power
back then they were talking about
kilobytes of data or even
megabytes of data so they did not have
in the super computers
so they wanted to make sure that they
don't have enough space so they are to
actually converted that to single letter
amino acid code in fact i learned all
these stories from people who work with
her
who are actually still a judge now right
coding storing information is efficient
that is correct so
now from that where did we head right
1950s
and of course you all know but watson
and creek right without watson click we
won't be here today
and then we have sender sequencing
without sequencer we could not have
sequenced anything
right so insulin was the first protein
and then if of course things started
evolving
we started seeing a lot a lot more
excuse me started seeing and then we
started seeing polymerase chain reaction
and then
and then we started seeing uh ncbi
and then we started seeing all of these
different databases
and it was in 1991
the official term bioinformatics was
coined and it came up in the literature
excuse me i think i'm screaming a lot
here
with out of excitement because of all of
you
right so then we started seeing all of
these tools that was developed and all
of those things and then we started
developing and a lot a lot of different
things started and you can actually pay
attention to here
where the whole genome project
initiative was actually started in the
80s
excuse me and then
and then the origin of bioinformatics
the first protein sequence reported was
that of
insulin 1956 it consisted of only one
51 amino acids and then
nearly a decade later the first nucleic
acid sequence was reported again there
is a faculty at georgetown who we
who actually passed away two years ago
jack shuriken he was the first person to
actually sequence a trna
when he was at princeton so